the jurgen experience i mean i grew up
loving woody allen and and that's a
tough as a jew from new york that's a
tough one to swallow right there it is
now try re-watching manhattan and if
you're comfortable watching it you're
probably a pedophile you know i don't
remember manhattan it's incredible but
it's [ __ ] weird what year was that
it's in the 70s it's uh black and white
it my friend ron on hershberg has a
great line about that movie where he
said it's basically a romantic comedy
for pedophiles because the end of the
the end of the movie is not like i
[ __ ] up by dating a high school girl
it's that he's sad that it didn't work
out
really yeah i might not have ever mariel
hemingway oh you know what i i
definitely didn't see it it's uh i mean
it's so she's in high school she's a you
get this she's 18
at dalton which is where jeffrey epstein
taught and uh this is the 70s that's
when he taught there alan and epstein
are but this is my i mean
it's a little weird right yeah
i mean here's the [ __ ] up part though
the opening is the most beautiful thing
i've ever seen in a movie it's just his
like love letter to new york it's
gorgeous
and i i grew up like worshiping woody
allen he's done some weird [ __ ] he
definitely has yeah i mean there's no
doubt about it he married his
stepdaughter i mean that enough that
that alone is not good yeah
no i mean that's crazy and then there's
allegations from the other uh kids
yeah were they coach were they not
i don't know the one kid yeah right yeah
i don't know but it's enough to go
it's enough to be blamed yeah it really
bummed yeah yeah you ever listened to
his stand-up his old stance it's
brilliant it's brilliant he was a great
that's what's where you're like oh
you're a great short story writer you're
a great stand-up you're a great
filmmaker and then you do some weird
jazz thing on the side that no one yeah
i have friends who are like do you want
to watch them like do do i want to watch
the thing he's fifth best at no
do you want to watch me play checkers no
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i don't want to watch
woody allen at the carlisle
i could give a [ __ ] i guess if i was
like really a hardcore woody allen fan
i'd go watch it just to see him do
something that he loves you know
maybe the carlisle where you pay 26
dollars for a manhattan i would go see
like hunter s thompson play drums you
know even if he sucked
just because such a hunter fan you know
i loved woody allen like that is like he
he loved new york in a way where we felt
cool as new yorkers to be like [ __ ]
woody it's woody allen i used to see him
on the street all the time and he was
just anytime you'd be like woody he'd
just like run it was amazing he just run
away from you
uh but i knew a
i was working at a summer camp in the
summer or something i was like a
counselor and i saw him and i was like
woody and he just ran
we're just him run away from kids but uh
you know uh woody allen
annie hall is like the i mean as comics
that's like the yeah that's like the
prototype right there where you're like
whoa you made it's also the perfect
rom-com because they don't end up
together
like there's so many it's such a run
hollywood at that time especially
rom-com
yeah and i ain't heating [ __ ] rules
yeah diane keaton's great
what was the film that he made with uh
who's the guy with the [ __ ] up nose
jeez ellen wilson owen wilson yeah we're
here what's
it is [ __ ] up it kind of works with
him because he's so handsome like having
that [ __ ] up nose kind of balances it
out where you like him more that's a
great movie midnight in paris it is very
good but it's him he's playing woody
allen like everyone is john cusack on
broadway yeah another great movie
another great movie what do you have are
you playing woody they all just feel
real bad about working with them now
though it's so strange yeah they try to
kind of defend him a little bit and no
one who's ever defended him like
i get i mean
they all kind of
avoid it when they can
but it's one of those things it's like
what do you do
yeah i mean it's tough he's one of the
greatest i mean polanski's another one
right you think of like the greatest
chinatown is one of the greatest movies
ever fantastic movie it's impossible to
watch that and not
see i'm not enough of a film guy to like
notice you know great cinematography
when you watch that movie you're like
every frame looks beautiful yeah
it's insane yeah sometimes creeps are
really good at a thing isn't it
[Laughter]
creeps are good too
that's the problem is throughout history
well you know when you're we were
talking about this the other day that
like socrates and plato a lot of these
guys that we associate with some of the
most brilliant things that anybody ever
wrote were pedophiles yeah like there
was a lot of that going on back then and
maybe that's where they got their their
powers or something [ __ ] kid just
makes you really good at your art i
don't know i don't think so no no
[Laughter]
but uh
what's his face uh
uh [ __ ] baldwin alec baldwin yeah
he's the only guy that like defends him
now
yeah pretty openly like i need some
allies yeah he needs somebody on his
team did you see tim dillon did alec
baldwin's podcast i thought that was
like the most on brand perfect thing i
saw that i was like good